Let me comment on the
merits of heatmaps
as a way of representing data
in the context of representing
crime activity.
Criminal activity-related
data often
has both components
of time and location.
Sometimes, all that is
required is a line chart,
but heatmaps can
visualize data that
will be too big for a table.
Plotting data on maps
is much more effective
than a table for location based
data, and is eye catching.
What is the edge of
predictive policing?
Many police forces are
exploiting their databases
to focus finite resources
on problem areas.
Not only do analytics
help improve policework,
the outputs are also
good communication tools
to decision makers in
government, and the wider
public.
The application of
analytics to data like this
is new and growing,
with companies
like PredPol and Palantir
leading the effort.